hey my name is Joanna Maura this is
sisal today I'm making chicken and
potatoes with some peppers in there it's
simple quick takes little effort so
right here we got some Yukon Gold
potatoes some red potatoes peppers lemon
chicken salt and pepper lemon pepper
always olive oil butter thyme garlic her
some basil leaves just a little a little
bit of ingredients kind of spice it up
and you definitely want your chicken
seasoned any potato seasoned so you not
eat a dry meal so I'm gonna preheat the
oven to 400 degrees turn that on I
started taking cooking more seriously
kind of when I was coming for us to put
on weight so I kind of take upon myself
to started cooking and going out to get
groceries at night I'm just putting it
in the effort start meal prepping and so
I could put on some way to be the best
football player I can I try to do the
best to kind of cook for everybody and
whenever I have some extras okay I
definitely give it to my teammates for
sure my mom's pretty good cook but I
kind of just tried to learn and learn my
own I just look look at recipes and try
to figure out what I can induce by
someone own thing here and there but for
the most part it's really watching
YouTube videos and just watching
watching recipes and reading cookbooks I
step one first of all you gotta wash
your potatoes always gotta wash your
food make sure you keep your hands clean
nothing
for inquire make sure the healthy people
you're cooking for so now she got
potatoes washed it's time to cut and
dice these up I'm not sure if it has to
cook with my teammates but I don't know
I think for myself I definitely able to
kind of cook making sure I'm giving up
my meals but I think my opposite from
opposition I think the most important
thing is keeping my weight up make sure
my nutritions right but I know if I'd be
able to ask her get asked about my
teammates or anything because I might
get forced to do as a rookie but we'll
see so now we're to cut into our peppers
fish you're watching your chickens
taking care of your chicken as much fun
as you say now cut off the fats a little
bit trim it down
we're Nigerian so we make my mom makes a
do some mountain I dream food always
different stuff I say some jollof rice
probably the best one yeah she that's
probably one of our favorite she makes
out all the time
jollof fries fufu kind of special way to
make fried rice we're huge fans of
plantains so that's definitely
incorporated a lot of the dishes and
chickens so there's all protein and
different variations of food that she
makes the foods are definitely typically
spicy so I'll probably say a lot of
pepper different types of peppers so you
got to be able to handle if you come
miles now we're gonna season these are
small tastes like salt and pepper but
then you can get creative with it I like
to throw on the pepper and all my stuff
on there thyme and basil kind of ways
kind of get a little flavors and uh get
this kit the kitchen smell and get it a
little bit and make sure you're
seasoning both sides can't season the
wine all right get back to our potatoes
some salt in there got a mixture so let
me use the top of this get our pan boil
potatoes in there lay it on top put your
lemons in there sprinkle the lemon juice
get a little flavor on there we'll make
a little make a little saucy here make
sure the chicken does go dry just going
to use some butter get that melted a
little bit microwave you know some olive
oil a little bit some time in there a
little bit more
[Music]
so right now got this going that's how
it looks pretty good
keep it in there for five forty-five to
fifty minutes clean up clean up the area
while that lots going on so that way
when it's done he's ready to eat
[Music]
my name is you acquire and thank you for
cooking with me